hello everyone and welcome back to the
greatest tournament there ever was and
will be i'm of course only kidding that
uh goes to the candidates tournament of
1959 but this one is uh definitely uh
well it could be a close second
especially if the players continue
playing like this it's a ding learning
versus
like i said round three of the
candidates tournament 2022
uh it's an unbelievable game uh where an
unbelievable blunder occurred or maybe
not a blunder yes a blunder but even
greater than the blunder was the
opportunity that was missed to punish
this blunder so i don't want to spoil
too much uh let's dive straight into it
and you guys will have a nice
opportunity to
improve on the play that was uh that
actually happened in the game so uh it's
ding with the white pieces and he opens
with d4 we have knight to f6 by rapport
c4 uh g6 knights to c3 and d5 we have
the groomfield defense uh c captures
knight characters and e4 we go for the
main line of the exchange variation
knight captures b captures and bishop to
g7 you see you guys see this all the
time especially if you like for example
uh nvls games we've bishop to c4 and now
c5 striking in the center uh knight to
e2 and here knight to c6 so just putting
more pressure yeah on that d4 square
bishop to e3 and here both players just
castle we have b6 by rapport
and now rook to c1 and we always say
that it makes sense to move this rook
sometimes
you put the rook on b1 but now that b6
was played the rook is better placed on
c1 so you don't have to worry about this
bishop so bishop to b7 and here we have
bishop to b5 interestingly ding already
had this position in the 2018 tata steel
india rapid tournament against spentala
harikrishna only he had it with the
black pieces and hari krishna played
queen to d2 here which is in fact the
strongest move recommended by the engine
but the ding got a fairly easy draw
in that game so here ding instead goes
for bishop to b5 it's the engine's
second favorite move but ding thinks
that it will pose more problems for for
a port so rook the c8 continuing
development queen to d2 now and c
captures on d4 we have c characters on
d4 and now uh like i said there is a
game that
reached this exact same position uh by
none other than maxine vashila grav who
plays the most groomfield the defenses
uh pretty much uh you know of all the
players uh where e6 was played by him he
played it against yuan yi in the video
grand prix this year in belgrade uh in
serbia and that game ended in a draw
however here we have queen to d6 by
rapport and it is now as of move 14 that
we have a completely new game uh so how
do you continue here he is trying to get
ding to push d5 so he can play knight to
e5 and obviously this will be very good
for him he he prepared this but the
thing just goes rook after d1 uh
continuing development before uh
deciding on any pawn pushers your center
here is beautiful you don't want to ruin
it too fast so queen to b4 offering a
queen trade and just queen d3 defending
the bishop and avoiding the queen trade
we have e6 and now uh ding starts
pushing with h4 he wants to play h6
maybe h5 maybe open up the position
maybe push the pawn all the way to h6 uh
all depends on what
rihard does and here you will probably
see h5 uh if someone goes h4 nowadays in
2022 you see h5 immediately and while
this is playable rapport goes for rook
d8 and this allows ding to go for a most
unusual idea uh here ding abandons the
center he plays bishop to g5 and he is
correct definitely it is the strongest
move recommended by the engine uh so now
rapport can start capturing on d4 but it
means ding will grab the rook here
uh you don't have to ask her up or twice
to sacrifice a little bit of material
you could also play a pawn to f6 but
that's just ruining your your king side
for seemingly nothing so instead just
knight captures on d4 and this is where
the fun really begins we have bishop
captures on d8 and now even though it
looks like you have some uh not right
now but rookie after 78 and even though
it looks like you have some discoveries
towards the white queen uh ding says uh
not to worry i just continue pushing
with h5 there really aren't any useful
discoveries uh the uh also the the other
thing you might consider is bishop to a6
this looks like a really really
fun move point is that after black makes
a move let's say queen b2 puts more
pressure on this knight on e2 uh king f1
defending the knight now we capture he
lets the bishop captures queen captures
now we can play something like
pawn to b5 we disconte disconnect uh the
queen's defense of the knight here so
now we are threatening to capture here
but now let's say knight to g1 and it's
a really really funny looking position
where white is better but black has a
very very active position for example
you go after the pawn we're gonna play
g3 and so on so this is one way to do it
but uh we are not engines we don't just
play engine moves uh
like that so dean continues pushing like
a normal human so h5 we have bishop to
e5 by rapport
and now a pawn to a4
defending that bishop so now the queen
can move uh and here we have king the g7
the safest way to play this for a rapper
would be just to trade everything knight
captures with cher queen captures rook
captures on d1 rook captures and now
king to g7 however in the game uh he
decided to go king to g7 right away
which is a a cooler way to play chess
leaving more material on the board but
now after king to f1
how do you how do you continue the game
now there's a problem uh not if you ask
rapport he says this is exactly the same
and i can still capture on e2 even
though it doesn't come with check and
that's exactly what he played he played
knight captures on e2 here and now
dink's position is completely winning
however it is not easy to see why so
feel free to pause the video here and
try to find the only winning idea for
ding
while i give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on realizing that
again the only winning move is the
obvious one and the one that was not
played in the game uh so for those of
you who just want to enjoy the show it
is a queen capture so rook and d8 it
seems like such a reasonable move to
play why wouldn't you play this uh but
that's uh
what being decided he decided not to
play this but still we're going to show
how complicated it is now why can't
black just capture on c1 the problem is
if knight captures on c1 there is again
only one winning idea for ding and most
likely the one that ding missed and that
is queen to g5 and now again you might
think is this really so strong uh the
question the the answer is yes it
definitely is because now you're just
threatening on the h6 check king goes
back and we deliver checkmate we rook to
d8 so we have to stop this also the
knight is still hanging the bishop is
still hanging so how can we defend this
with black well we're going to play
bishop to c7 uh we have to prevent the
roof from infiltrating but now just h6
with check king the g8 and now queen the
f6 threatening checkmate queen to f8
blocking this or rather guarding against
checkmate and now rook to d7 and now uh
one of the bishops will fall uh you
can't really move the bishop anywhere
because then rook to d8 so there really
isn't a good move here for black once
black plays something let's say knight
b3 we just capture on c7 and that's it
let's say knight d2 check you have some
moves here captures here attacks the
queen we're just going to move the queen
and that's pretty much it once the
bishop moves because the bishop is
attacked you can't move the queen
because this is still checkmate so
whatever you make i just rook the c8 and
that's it queen captures let's say and
of course queen to g7 is checkmate so
that's uh the line that ding most likely
missed but of course we have to show the
other one as well in case uh that's not
what actually happened in ding's mind uh
the problem is okay you don't have to
play knight captures and c1 what about
queen captures an e4 this is also very
scary just uh threatening queen captures
and g2 again not a problem just bishop
captures an e2 we actually allow queen
captures on g2 and now after this is
played
you have to calculate all of the checks
and it's uh definitely not an easy thing
to do but it is winning and it's not um
uh like it's uh you know beyond the
ding's ability to calculate uh precisely
so i and he didn't really invest all
that much time uh in this position so
king to e1 now queen h1 check let's say
we play king to d2 we don't we don't
mind okay the bishops and the queen it's
an open board the king on d2
let's say bishop f4 check king to see c3
we're still attacking the queen queen to
c6 with check king to b3 now we can grab
the rook bishop captures on c1 but now
queen to d4 with check and now there
isn't a good way to play this because if
you move the king just h captures and g6
uh and there there's not all that all
that much you can do here uh
it's a really really really tough
position if you capture here then even
queen to h8 can be played if you play f
captures here then queen to h4 with
check is very scary king to g7 now queen
to e7 with checking to h6 queen
sorry not f7 queen to f8 with check and
now now finally after king to g5 we can
activate the rook with rook to g1
and that's it once you
move the king with the king to h4 you
don't have any other squares as the
bishop also covers the light square so
king here queen to a7 check king h3
we're gonna capture here with check and
that's it only move is bishop h6 and
this will be checkmate so yeah you can't
really do that the king cannot go here
the only way to play this is to block
with f6
and did not we just trade queen to d7
with check so of course if you trade
real captures with check picks up the
bishop on b7 so king to h6 uh would be
played let's say captures captures and
now we just trade queen captures bishop
captures and rook captures on c1 and you
are up
a full rook yes black has three extra
pawns but it's it's still a full rook so
of course white will be completely
winning here so that's why queen
captures and d8 is just crushing for
ding however ding played queen captures
on e2 and his position is still better
but not nearly as good as it would be if
he captured on d8
uh so here rook captures on d1 uh with
check rook captures and now pawn to a6
attacking the bishop giving ding further
chances here just the bishop to d4
is the way to go yes you're still down
the exchange but once you close the
position with bishop d4 and e5 uh
there's just not all that much to look
for here uh for white for example queen
c4 you can even trade here doesn't
really matter captures captures e5 and
it will be incredibly difficult for
white to make a breakthrough here the
rook just doesn't have open lines and
you know the rook really needs open
lines to be um
a strong piece so instead rapper played
a6 and this again gives things some
chances bishop captures an a6 we have
bishop characters queen captures and now
he picks up the pawn on e4 but now
ding has a couple of very good options
here but he plays rook the e1 and this
is the worst one uh what you want to
play here is just trade ones characters
captures and play queen to e2 the the
point is
and it's uh of course now that you know
about it it makes sense that
we cannot trade queens the position
would be winning for white so once the
queen moves and you have to move
somewhere to defend the bishop now we
just play king to g1 and there's no good
way for uh black to set up a barrier
black needs to have this
bishop on d4 and the pawn on e5 to make
the the rook useless because uh the
bishop here guards the pawn here the
pawn here guards the bishop and the rook
will not be able to defeat the bishop
basically uh but now you don't have a
way to do this it bishop the c3 we just
attacked the bishop or for a queen trade
and now
if you play a queen to f6 you still
can't play e5 because the bishop would
hang if you play queen e5 you can't push
e5 because there's a queen there and
it's just uh very very difficult for for
black to find moves here and here dean
would have excellent winning chances
however he played rook to e1 and this is
not much different now comes queen to d4
uh queen to e2 attacking the bishop now
bishop to f6 we have h captures h
captures and now queen to e4 offering a
queen trade and defending the pawn here
now queen to d2 and here after rook to
e2 we have queen to d1 check rook the
one queen to d2 so how do you make
progress here
g4 g3 was played but now bishop to d4
and now bishop to d4 comes with tempo as
rapport is threatening checkmate here so
ding had to defend but now just queen to
c3 uh we have rook to d1 but now queen
to c6 again
uh with a with a very tricky idea not
just attacking the pawn but also if rook
captures here then queen to h1 is just
checkmate a very very nice find this
queen to c6 idea by rapper you don't
have to play it you could do it the
boring way you could play e5 the move
that we've discussed and now the rook
will just not have any anything to do
but queen to c6 is much much cooler so
here after queen to c6 we have queen the
g for now with a double attack here also
freeing up d2 square for the king but
not just e5 and now there's really no
way to do anything here the bishop
guards both of these pawns and there's
no way to make progress here for ding so
ding just gave up he played rook
captures on d4 and this is basically a
draw for captures captures with czech
king to g8 and now he forces a draw as i
believe he was very much disgusted with
himself king the g8 and he was in this
position on move 40 upon reaching time
control that dingler and richard rapport
agreed to a draw in round three of
defeated candidates tournament 2022 so
really really an amazing uh
turn of events here uh ding missing a
brilliant opportunity to bounce back in
a tournament with a victory against
rapport um uh it's just uh i don't know
if you guys remember in the previous
maybe
not maybe not in the previous but maybe
two videos ago i mentioned that um uh
caruana and the dinger are the players
that play the most complicated games
that can be calculated and here ding had
a position you know really that fits his
style where you just have to brutally
calculate everything and just force a
win and he got that but he just wasn't
able to do it and he didn't spend all
that much time trying to do it he
is just that
his spidey sense didn't go off and uh
that's uh you know that's that's a big
problem as this was a great opportunity
for him to bounce back uh but also this
is a great opportunity for rapport as he
doesn't lose and he just continues um
you know the the candidates on a high
note uh so yeah uh that's uh the game
hope you guys enjoyed it the ding will
go into a rest day feeling uh not all
that rested i i imagine uh so hopefully
he he gets some rest um i would like to
thank andrew lastova johan they're king
aravind kumar vendeli and for your
contribution to my channel uh for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and i will see
you soon continuing the coverage of the
candidates until it finishes
thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day